you're getting no PM Gabi's a naive okay
usually they take it like a noon Gabby
oh my god no just like less obnoxious oh
now you guys know the backstory welcome
to another ask dr. Mike episode I have
the lovely Gabby Hanna with you today
she knows amazing work on her channel
talking about all sorts of experiences
trying some dieting stuff doing
lifestyle videos you even have a music
video that was like crushing the charts
this year yeah that was cool
that was awesome I don't new one coming
up oh what's that one called monster
it's actually a super mental healthy
song I love that you're talking about
mental what inspired you to do that by
the way like I'm curious I just suffered
with a lot of mental health issues and
I've always been really open about it
with my followers and I found it was
like oh I hope so
but I actually found that once I started
talking about it because I tried to hide
it for so long that's when I started
healing and I'm in such a like healthy
happy genuinely good place and it wasn't
until I started talking about it and
just kind of ripped myself open and gave
it to the world that well responds like
from the community it was great I mean
first of all the YouTube community who
started talking to me about it was like
thank you so much for talking about this
I've never been able to but you put it
into words and then obviously there's so
many people out there that relate to
like anxiety and depression eating
disorders and then they were seeing
somebody who they kind of looked up to
suffer with the same stuff and I don't
know I just I'm hoping that it's
starting a dialogue a little bit with it
I think you don't talk about it enough I
mean I just watched your recent video on
sort of the psychology behind social
media stars yeah yeah and I related to
that a lot because when I first started
doing Instagram like five years ago I
was a huge Darce assist and I didn't
grow up being a narcissist
it made me that for that time period
because I would go around showing people
how many followers I had how many likes
I got just like everything go it starts
becoming an addictive process and
Jonathas aren't born they're made
okay I mean that that's it yes there's
definitely a genetic component there's
definitely a nature component there's a
predisposition but for the most part I
was actually watching a psychologist
talk about this where narcissism is one
of like the very few mental disorders
where it's almost entirely
you were raised as opposed to being born
and that's the difference between
psychopathy and sociopathy two is one is
born and one is raised there's sure yeah
I mean look I've seen it debated both
ways and yeah I think there's definitely
room for nature versus nurture
discussion yeah you're the doctor I'm
not going to be you wanted it about the
baby I don't claim to be an expert at it
I'm looking at things from the clinical
side yeah I do some research on my own
but I have a lot of experience in
treating people who have some mental
health issues obviously physical health
issues because that's part of what I do
and a big thing that I've noticed is
there's been a huge uptick and anxiety
symptoms depressive symptoms yeah and in
making some of the youtube videos that
people are making on the subject I get a
little upset really yeah
and I'll tell you why like the
difference between let's say a
narcissistic personality trait versus a
narcissistic personality disorder oh
please go off doctor money this is so
important I didn't know you're gonna say
please go oh no no they sound incredibly
similar and when you're talking in
comment on you're just saying narcissist
right you're not yes defining them and
in reality there's a small but very
important difference between the two so
you can have a narcissistic personality
trait and be totally foggy almost
everybody does and and have success yes
not to a degree everyone has it to some
sort of degree I guess you can say but
then if you have a disorder that means
it's gotten so bad that it's affecting
major aspects of your life function I'm
talking about work your ability to
sustain a job sustain a relationship
achieve happiness in your life and
well-being creating a lot of anxiety
depression that sort of things so
there's people that are raging
narcissists and exhibit narcissistic
personality traits who are very
successful and don't have the disorder
right but when I watch some of these
videos everyone's very quick to throw
out these terms because they're using
them in plain English but from a medical
side it's a little inaccurate and a
little bit disingenuous because people
are getting labeled too soon the idea of
mental health and whole concept mental
health is so complicated and confounded
even when you're talking about
sociopaths right that was a big subject
on your video yeah so sociopaths
in medicine we don't even have the term
sociopath away of antisocial personality
disorder right right you've studied that
yeah and when we talking about labeling
people's sociopaths we need to be very
careful because if someone is under the
influence of drugs let's say whatever
they're taking they could be abusing
adderall or they could be using cocaine
or marijuana or alcohol and they're
acting a certain way because they're
under the influence of drugs you can't
really call them sociopaths or having
antisocial personality disorder because
are they just doing that because of
they're under the influence so they
could be showing sociopathic tendencies
and not be a sociopath and again a very
small difference but very important
right it's very easy to get labeled
something and have that label stuck with
you
incorrectly your entire life and I think
it's also to not try to diagnose people
a if you're not doctor and B if you've
never met that person like you can't
look at somebody's YouTube videos no
it's not even about you can't even by
meeting somebody yeah like I need
multiple visits to get down to the
bottom of what's bothering somebody and
why they're having so much differently
and also like different social
situations or if you're like a young kid
who wants to get attention and feel big
you might go to school and act a certain
way but at home you're actually really
compassionate yeah loving person yes so
think about a person who suffers from
bipolar disorder right example and then
to soar self-medicate they use all sorts
of substances right this is a
hypothetical example now that person
because they're having extreme mania at
times which they're very hyper and
they're also using drugs at that point
they can exhibit all sorts of tendencies
narcissistic tendencies sociopath
tendencies but they're not any of those
things yeah they're actually suffering
from bipolar disorder and a substance
abuse disorder which are two different
things but in order to get there imagine
what person doesn't come in they say I
have bipolar disorder and I drink
everybody that's got it you have to get
that person's trust yeah you have to
hear them out and hear how they what
their thought process is like where
they're having difficulties in life how
they view certain situation and their
family history and how they grew up
yeah so I incredibly dislike when people
start diagnosing people just either from
their YouTube channel or from meeting
them once or twice because it's just
inaccurate
yeah there's gonna be faults and you're
gonna unfairly judge people but even if
it is accurate yeah unless you're doing
some proper education so yeah that's my
thoughts on it I just think that people
need to tread carefully in this
territory because labeling people I know
people get very wound up when I say
labeling right they're like oh I don't
want to be labeled that I have bipolar
disorder look you have a diagnosis a
diagnosis it doesn't mean that anything
is quote unquote bad about you it just
means that you have something going on
that we can help but that's also I we
need to talk about mental illness more
because obviously everybody knows about
the stigma around mental illness where
it's like embarrassing to be told you're
borderline personality or have bipolar
or something critical a treatable
illness that you need help with and
people are so ashamed and I just think
that's so sad it's sad it's a very
difficult situation because it deters
people - from getting help it deters me
from getting health
it causes substance abuse disorders
because they're trying to self-medicate
without exposing themselves to others so
the more open we can be about it and
honest in these conversations that's why
I don't like labeling people too early
have the conversation with your dog
first and then figure out where it goes
but then something I'll also say against
the medical community against my folks
is that we often jump to a diagnosis too
soon both mentally and physically the
mind can really be divided into two sort
of areas you have a conscious and
unconscious mind conscious is everything
you're thinking about now you know
whether or not you want to pick this cup
up that's in your conscious right and
then your subconscious is everything
that your baggage from childhood you
know what are you upset about from an
inferiority complex worries about being
perfect in your life wanting to achieve
the best result possible so that you can
prove someone wrong like you're not
actively thinking about those things but
they exist in your mind when you have
very powerful emotions that starts
stacking up and your unconscious that
you refuse to acknowledge if you can
consistently repress them which your
mind wants to do why because if they
come out you're gonna break down you're
gonna start crying you won't be able to
work you may even hurt yourself so to
protect you your mind does a few
interesting things and one of those
things is it gives you symptoms symptoms
like anxiety if you think about what
anxiety is let's take social anxiety
it's a fear of something that's not
actually life-threatening right like if
you go hang out with friends no one's
gonna kill you I mean yeah unless
there's a crazy circumstance but
generally no one's gonna care you grow
up because my Brooklyn yeah but in
general no one's there to harm you with
your friends but people that have social
anxiety create an anxiety their mind
creates this anxiety and it doesn't mean
that there's something wrong with them
their mind is protecting them by causing
them to worry about that social anxiety
instead of their repressed emotions
because those seem to be so dangerous
that let's have them worry about
something not so dangerous instead but
it also does the same thing from a
physical aspect let's have this person
have a muscle spasm and have some back
pain right now oh wow and they'll be
thinking about their back pain how to
treat it what doctors see they'll
complain about it and I'm gonna be
thinking about the repressed emotions so
what I started doing where you're
pressing motions cause muscle spasms
yeah absolutely
not just muscles passing this there's
been research done on this that some of
these repressed emotions can go into the
form of acid reflux chronic cough so
many unique these are all my issues
allergies rashes I feel like I'm reading
WebMD right now no again I'm not saying
that repressed emotions are the source
of all your problem no yeah I'm saying
is because this started off by me saying
how the medical communities have fault a
little bit right and what I was saying
is that the medical community is at
fault because we're often quick to just
say there has to be some kind of
cellular process that's going on that's
wrong or there has to be some sort of
muscle spasm or a broken bone or an
impingement I know they're coming from
like your mind yeah so what I do with my
patients is first of all I rule out a
physical cause that's the first thing
that I do and a medical cause obviously
like if you have something wrong with
your thyroid that can cause some issues
with your muscles and all these things
right everything medically and
physically I try and rule out first the
most dangerous things first and then
move down the line once I realize
everything's fine and we try some you
conservative therapies like physical
therapy some home exercise program
stretching icing that sort of thing for
physical pain and then it doesn't work
or the pain fluctuates and I see that it
has a very unique history to where the
person keeps getting these aches and
pains I bring them in I just have a
conversation with them and it's a simple
conversation about like what's going on
in your life what was childhood like
it's not very in detail initially right
and what people do and what they've
learned to do is they repress their
emotions incredibly in ways that will
surprise you for example I'll ask a
person I think this would be actually
fun right now okay I'm gonna do this
with you on camera but hope you're ready
for this
over there because I don't know but if I
were to ask you about your childhood
okay and you'd bring up a painful memory
of childhood the appropriate response is
if it hurt you and you were upset by it
would be to cry right but your brain
doesn't want you to cry cuz you're on
camera there's a person here that you
don't really have a familiarity with
yeah so when your brain does is it
encourages you to smile how often have
you heard people talk about a very
painful thing that happens to them but
they smile while they do it that's like
my mo for sure yeah so that is a form of
oppression and me as a doctor when I see
this happen all I have to do is ask the
person can I interrupt you for one
second tell me right now you're telling
me a very painful story why are you
smiling and people break down they start
crying they understand that these
emotions are very powerful and they've
never appreciated I start solving right
now you look at people like folks like
comedians who are very funny they have a
high amount of you know mental issues oh
yeah and we're talking about anxiety
depression and all these things because
comedy is a great outlet for that same
thing a smiling
another thing I hear people say is ya
had probably a messed up childhood
they'll say words like that where
they're sort of mitigating they won't
you know anyway admit yeah so they'll
keep using these blocking words and
they'll say you know probably was a bad
childhood well drinking was probably
hurting my marriage and I'll have to
stop them and say okay honestly right
now was marriage was drinking hurting
your marriage and they'll say yeah it
was okay so stop saying probably when
you're telling the story and just having
that having the
connect to their emotions be becoming an
eyeful helps a lot yeah I've had
patients completely cure their back
pains their elbow pains their acid
reflux symptoms just by connecting them
to their internal thoughts and dialogue
because life forces us to repress and
sometimes that repression is needed
because like if you're in a job
interview or something you can't just
start sobbing about something that
happened in childhood right so sometimes
you need to repress but uh other times
we need that outlet we need that ability
so what you're doing on camera I've seen
even videos of you crying
right there exist so many there's so
many powerful right and you're people
get really mad at me for crying people
shouldn't get mad what I think it's good
for you and you even mentioned it that
now that you're happier and healthier as
a result even though you cried yes that
you found an outlet for it yeah and
people find different I honestly I will
say I've had my entire life chronic neck
back pain so many character
chiropractors so many massage therapists
like trying to figure out why my neck is
always too big and all that and ever
since I started getting myself and check
and of course some of it came out like
training and stuff but I have so little
back and neck pain now that I'm
emotionally happy and so open with my
feelings and I don't change physically
it's not like you had a surgery that fix
you know I mean like obviously working
out with like strengthen your muscles
and hopefully keep some look that
healthy so that's not so many
it's mental and what I notice a lot is a
lot of these treatments that we do like
physical therapy acupuncture injections
surgeries even some of them work they
work on fixing the symptoms temporarily
and then something pops up so first your
neck hurt you got an injection now your
elbow hurts then your elbow gets
injections are you talking about well
like steroid injections so let you do
that like anti-inflammatory injection
yeah I never I never had ones I never
knew how people get down to their knees
for us to my own your foot right now oh
no
I thought I wonder what this whole time
okay it's good
so like knee injections whatever so
people get a lot of treatments and our
medical community facilitates this
because it's easy because if I have 15
minutes with a patient I can't go and
start talking about their childhood but
I can say oh well you have arthritis
that's why your knee hurts yeah why did
it hurt more today when you had a
stressful incident with your family than
it did yesterday right you know so we
have to be aware of this mental
component and because of our time
limitations we often don't because of
our research funding not being put
towards mental health we don't so I'd
become more and more proponent of this
I'm an osteopathic physician I'm a do
not an MD I had a Sports Medicine focus
initially when I started treating my
patients I saw so many patients for back
pain and I felt like I wasn't helping a
lot of them and now that I started using
this approach and I'm not doing anything
revolutionary I really just started
having honest conversations with them to
connect them to their to their thoughts
to have them understand that they may be
repressing a lot and just by opening
that up opening those floodgates I feel
a lot better and so far it's such a
low-risk
option the only risk is I spend some
time that's it that's really it that I
spend extra time with that patient and
that could probably have benefits on its
own actually so quote one time I think
was on Bates Motel of all things but she
was talking to a therapist and he said
why why do you hold that in and she said
or why don't people talk about their
feelings and she said because then
people would walk around cry all the
time and he was like what's wrong with
that well exactly yeah we're pressing
and obviously there's there's a time and
a place but it's interesting that people
are so embarrassed to like talk about
like a painful childhood yeah because
people don't want to admit that they
didn't have some type of picture-perfect
like look I've seen it from all angles
being a doctor I've seen people who are
so eager to share that story with
anybody where it's inappropriate like
yeah they'll come up to my front desk
person and start sharing their childhood
it's like well ya know some boundaries
probably something there too I'm saying
so it comes from all different sides
there's extremes on either end and I try
and figure out what the most balanced
approaches and there's a doctor who just
passed away recently name is dr. Soran
know I read his book it's called a
divided mind a lot of my initial
thoughts came for
reading his book and he gave a very
funny example and I think you'll
appreciate he was on a cruise ship with
his wife traveling okay and he was
having some symptoms of acid reflux like
he was having an upset stomach and he
never got that he knew he didn't have an
ulcer or any of these things so he
started looking internally what's
causing me to have these symptoms he
couldn't figure out but when he got home
all the symptoms resolved like no more
acid reflux completely and he thought
about it and he realized there's an
inner child in all of us called the it'd
probably fried yet when you studied
psychology and this child wants all the
narcissist stuff they once pleasure all
the time it wants all the attention on
them and wants all the likes it wants
all the comment that sin doesn't want to
do anything for anybody then we have
this other part of our minds called the
ego which keeps that in check and says
well no you can't just have everything
for you you have to help out others you
have to do these things then there's the
super-ego and it gets past that but
let's just focus on the it'd he realized
his in didn't want to be on that trip he
doesn't like traveling but he knew his
wife did so he was there for his wife
and he was doing that because he wants
to be in a healthy and loving
relationship and he was having acid
reflux as a result then he thought if I
came to this conclusion and then started
having this emotion that I would get mad
at my wife maybe it's worth trading some
upset stomach to not be mad at my wife
right
so sometimes repression actually works
yeah but my job is to allow you to have
control over it so that sometimes you
want to repress in a given situation
like you're on a trip with your
significant other great but on other
times where you need to have an outlet
you know how to connect to that side of
things
that's what can cry on YouTube and then
get you slower and then be encouraged
that's a way that you chose to make it
yourself and we're all not perfect we're
all learning my knowledge of medicine is
limited
everyone's knowledge of medicine is
limited like we don't have a total cure
for foot fungus like toenail fungus is
that crazy like you would think like all
we cured so much we can't even cure
toenail fungus well so like when I look
at some experts live give up Tony Alva's
yeah especially as they get older in our
immune system that's gonna be there for
you in the future so be careful of nail
salons only go to ones you trust I never
get pedicures just you can get it on
your hands too
oh great but that's my biggest thing why
I have my youtube channel is because I
try and encourage people to understand
that anyone who's overly confident
overly promising that they have all the
answers oh my god this is so good we're
gonna be like spilling tea right now I
can't believe I'm gonna be spilling tea
did you hear about those youtubers I
don't even know their names that claim
they were dying recently no there's some
gaming guys and I saw briefly
they said they were dying and then
someone called them out on it cuz well
you don't know who they were they have
names a whole channel like 4 million
subs and they they have these 4 million
subs they said they were dying it was
unclear what they were dying from but
they said that they saw a doctor there
were two of them two of them both of
them are dying at the same time and they
saw a chiropractor who they said cured
them from dying and someone called them
out and made a response video to them
and there was drama about it and then
they saw a chiropractor I know I know
let's go in judgment-free Africa
judgment-free yeah so wait I'm sorry
were they dying from like uh it was I
know like what was unknown at the time
and then someone called them out on it
and then they made a video saying that
they were proving that people were
proving that they were dying okay and
they showed proof that one of them was
taking a lot of medications for what
looked like a kidney issue or some
autoimmune issue with immune system
attacks itself back in the day they show
that evidence of him taking those pills
it was very dramatic I watched parts of
it but the thing that bothered me most
about the video is now that they're
talking about that they're dying and
they're trying to get views or whatever
it is that they're doing because one of
them said that when he meant that he was
dying he was saying that he was having
such bad anxiety and depression that he
could have committed suicide that's what
he meant when he was done which is okay
I stretch for me and look whatever
anyone wants to put out about their own
emotions I support that's their call but
what bothered me is they said that this
doctor can cure anything he has the
answer to anything that was a quote from
their video so them talking about them
dying I am know whatever they want to do
go do it I'm not gonna even judge that
cuz I don't know their medical eyes
all you okay but I don't know their
medical history I need more to the side
well like are these people gonna come
and be like no cuz actually uh this
person a lot of people don't like what
they're doing because they also like
give away iPhones on those videos Oh
literally they're like we're dying but
we're giving away iPhones so follow us
and follow we're checking their social
blade after this that's crazy they they
lost a lot of followers after that but
whatever so my biggest problem is that
they said this doctor can cure anything
be wary of doctors that say they can
cure anything or over-promised things
yeah the smartest people in the world
will be the first people to tell you
that they don't know in fact the more
you study at the PhDs everywhere so I
must be a genius
well the fact that you appreciate you
that you don't know a lot is a powerful
start because as people study and like
you look at like high school right like
you know a little bit then you go into
college you know more and then PhD I
couldn't compare since how much you know
to what you think you know right HD
drops drastically because as a PhD you
realize I have so many more questions
than I have answers right and even the
answers that we have as PhDs and
doctorates we know that in the future
those answers are gonna be proven wrong
right like initially we thought one
thing and then we totally changed our
medicine changes so much I learned more
about it what would you say to people
because we're talking about like having
an outlet and stuff yep
so I actually said something in a video
once I was like I say like don't let
your pain go to waste like do something
creative with it and somebody commented
where there's like I'm just like not
creative like I can't paint I can't draw
I can't write like I'm not a creative
artistic person so what should I do and
I was like I guess I don't know like if
you're not somebody who like sports or
art like what what do you do well I have
a good answer for those people first of
all I applaud you saying that to get
people an outlet because what you're
talking about is something I mentioned a
lot it's called ptg okay you've heard of
post-traumatic stress disorder PTSD
right coming home from war know if
you're a domestic abuse survivor you
know you have PTSD it's possible but we
hear a lot about that in the news PTSD
but you never hear ptg PSG's
post-traumatic growth it's a person who
have gone through something horrible
some kind of trauma like war like cancer
family member who had cancer
and they come out after this traumatic
episode and they grow as a person they
become better they find an outlet for
their struggle right very similar to
what you're talking about with yourself
like you said you were going through
some mental issues and from that you
learned that you became better and you
started educating people educating
yourself
that's ptg you're you're an example of
post-traumatic growth I've never heard
that term
there's no it's not in literature it's
not something that you would find I came
up with into my own mind but I've also
now saw other people mention it they
didn't steal it for me I didn't steal
from them we just it's it's a sort of
another line of thinking probably I
think you so PCG it's something
important so giving them an outlet is
smart because they can grow from it with
that being said a lot of people will say
well what can I do I don't have a
strength right that's something so
common right and my thing is ask five
people who know you best and ask them to
write the number one quality that they
think you have whatever it is and you
can use that quality to achieve pretty
much anything that's sure and people say
well no doctor cuz like people say I'm
funny and I want to be a doctor how is
that gonna help and I pose them a very
simple question who do you think in
terms of patient population like Ages of
patients what do you think needs to
laugh and enjoys laughing the most if
you're gonna be a doctor
kids wrong any other guesses adults Oh
word okay I feel like you know I'm like
a teacher will stump you in class yeah
and it's like that obvious answer and
everybody gets really annoyed no but
it's not doing everything and think
about it when you're sick and you're
going through a rough time don't you
want to laugh even more yeah because
everyone rightfully so is being very
serious and somber around you to not
upset you but then if someone comes in
with a little bit of humor it helps it
yeah that's a good pressure release
valve and I can always say that if you
have some sort of strength that people
find in you I can find a way to make it
fit your goals no that's so true so it's
really we grew up in a society when were
you born in 91 I was born in 89 so we're
almost the same age and we grew up in
this timeframe in the 90s where a lot of
self-esteem was just pushed on us like
parents were saying to us that we're all
special Charlie generation we're are
amazing participant participation
trophies this is great and what the
problem with that is
it breeds a lot of narcissistic
tendencies mm-hmm why because you'll
grow you'll go into a social setting
with a group of people and you may do
something really wrong socially like you
may start screaming when you shouldn't
be screaming or you'll make really
obnoxious jokes that don't make sense
for the moment right and when people try
and tell you like socially a command
that was not right or you should have
done something different there you say
who are you to critique me I'm special I
have self-esteem
I just won't hang out with you anymore
I'm going to find someone else so you
don't take critique well you don't take
criticism well you don't like discipline
people who forego all those things lead
to lead lives that are very unhappy
right because discipline will power all
these things you need to go through
struggles you need to set challenges for
yourself because there's no such thing
as a perfect utopia just how you'll
never know when something's hot unless
you felt something cold so the same way
that you need to go through a struggle
and feel like what it's like to struggle
that you'll when you actually surpass it
on your own and you do something then
you get that self-esteem from reaching
that struggle and that sort of
self-esteem is really good so as parents
what I tell people is instead of just
blessing all your kids all the time with
this is amazing even though you do this
horrible you know like dinosaur that
looks like a couch right you know so
give your kids challenges that are on
their level but then they can surpass
and now I'll give them their own level
of self-esteem that you don't need to
give them false praise for us right wow
we just covered a lot of bases wait am I
supposed to my supposed to get them no
you're supposed to just like asking me
things that have oh okay you wondered
about health like you're gonna ask me
anything well I'm all I'm all about like